spring in Ohio Graphica Republican
Congressman Mike Turner it's good to
have you here these numbers are
staggering call for number one
um this is the gross and unaccompanied
minors each month since Biden took
office in January of 2021 and you could
just that's a steady steady increase sir
this is just heartbreaking because what
you see in these numbers is the the real
impacts upon individuals and certainly
some of the most vulnerable people that
we see crossing the border you know
they've had a very treacherous uh
Journey all as a result of the failed
Biden policies where they have the open
border encouraging people to risk the
lives of their children and to send them
up to the border now the administration
as you know claims that the border is
secure but it clearly is not as we see
the pictures over 2 million people have
been apprehended crossing the border
just in the past year now to give you
some perspective where I'm from in
Southwest Ohio around Dayton Ohio
there's 1.2 million people who live
there so this is more than people who
who you know reside in an entire
Community who have gotten up and walked
across the border but with these
children you're seeing some of the worst
conditions some of the worst effects and
this is completely a result of of Biden
declaring in effect the Border open and
welcoming people to come I think we get
lost in the numbers frankly we're
talking about unaccompanied children
right and no Mom they know Dad no aunts
no uncle and the numbers are 267 000.
and those are the ones for comparison
for the okay for comparison Donald Trump
had ten thousand right ten thousand yeah
which is a lot it's a lot you're right
but it's this is a fraction of what
we're seeing now
right and think they don't just show up
on the border it's not that they're just
transported from their their homes of
safety to the Border they've made a
treacherous pass many uh having the most
brutal conditions
um and and some of the most you know
heartbreaking conditions and all a
result of the fact that this
Administration will not secure the
border the fact that they've declared
the Border open they're welcoming
um the these numbers are totally a
result of the administration calling
people to come into our country
another topic that we want to get to
we're following the story about the
pro-life activist Mark Houck uh he was
arrested at his home in Pennsylvania
there's a discrepancy between what the
wife says happened in front of their
seven children she says there were 25
agents lots of guns drawn the FBI saying
this that no SWAT team or SWAT operators
were involved that FBI agents knocked on
Mr Hogg's front door identified
themselves as FBI agents and asked him
to exit the residence he did so and was
taken into custody without incident
pursuant to an indictment but Senator
Hawley is calling on the FBI to answer
for more right Congress definitely has a
role here because what we are concerned
about is obviously unequal application
of the law we're worried about
persecution individuals who are
persecuted because their beliefs are
there or uh their political affiliation
but what you have here even if you look
at what the accusations are against them
and accept them as true which is you
know they're disputed it still doesn't
justify this level of an invasive
confronting
um arrest or the FBI going to his home
many times people especially when
there's a non-non-violent it's not like
this guy is a gun Runner right he's no
major threat to uh to his his family or
the community they can ask people to
even surrender they can you know
approach them when they're in their
driveway away from their family they
don't have to escalate this and make
this the most intrusive and that's I
think we're concerned about the abusive
discretion uh and this being you know
someone being persecuted for their
beliefs or or their political
affiliation sounds like there's more
questions out there hopefully we get the
answers soon meanwhile six weeks from
today you got a midterm election you're
from Ohio what happens what does America
decide well I think people are very fed
up with what they're seeing from the
Biden Administration they want it
stopped they they want inflation to be
reined in they understand that it's
directly a result of this
administration's policy that they're out
of control spending is causing pain and
inflation at the grocery store and for
their families they understand that
they're at War policies against energy
are costing them money at the pump and
making it more difficult for them to
provide for their families and they know
that this unsecure border is resulting
in human tragedy as you were just
reporting but also an unbelievable
effect to our country and a burden Upon
Our Nation so Republicans sweep it
I think that everyone wants that these
policies stopped and they know unless
there's a change in the House of
Representatives this Administration is
going to continue with policies that are
overwhelmingly hurting America and are
unpopular well we'll see we'll see how
they vote Mike Turner thank you for your
time good to have you appreciate that
thanks I'm Steve Ducey I'm Brian
Kilmeade and I'm Ainsley Earhart and
click here to subscribe to the Fox News
YouTube page to catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis